We now revisit the polling
problem that we
have started earlier.
When we first looked at that
problem, we used the Chebyshev
inequality to obtain certain
bounds and numerical results.
What we want to do now is
instead to use a central limit
theorem-type approximation,
which we hope that it will be
more accurate and more
informative.
Let us remind ourselves
of the setting.
We want to estimate a certain
number, p, which is the
fraction of the population
that will vote yes in a
certain referendum.
And we estimate p by picking a
sample out of the population.
We pick n people.
We pick them randomly, uniformly
over the population
and independently.
For each one of the people in
the sample, we ask them if
they will vote to yes or no,
and then we record their
answers in Bernoulli random
variables, Xi.
So by the assumptions that we
have made, these Xi's are
independent Bernoulli random
variables, and their mean is
equal to p.
We count how many X's
were equal to 1.
That's the number of yeses.
We divide by n, and that gives
us the fraction in the
population that have
responded yes.
This is the sample
mean of the X's.
And we use this sample
mean to estimate the
unknown fraction p.
We would like the error in our
estimation to be small, that
is the difference between the
sample mean and the true value
p to be small, less,
let's say, than
one percentage point.
Now there's no way of
guaranteeing that this spec
will be met with certainty,
unless we sample almost
everyone in the population.
But what we can do instead
is to ask that these
specifications are violated with
only a small probability.
So we look at the probability
that our estimation error is
larger than what we want.
This is the case that we do
not meet the specs, and we
would like this probability
to be small.
One possible question is what
the value of n should be in
order to meet the specs.
But in order to do any
calculations, we first need a
way of approximating
this probability.
We will do that using the
central limit theorem.
The central limit theorem
involves this standardized
version of the random variable
Sn, where Sn stands for the
sum of the X's.
We know that this random
variable is
approximately normal.
And what we want to do now is to
take this event and rewrite
it in an equivalent way but
which involves this random
variable Zn.
Let us start.
First, we note that here we a
mu and a sigma, so we should
know what these are.
For a Bernoulli random variable,
the mean is what we
already wrote down, and sigma
is the square root of p
times 1 minus p.
Now let's look at this event.
Mn is the same as Sn/n,
by definition.
And we can write p in this
form, minus n times
p divided by n.
And we want this quantity
to be larger
than or equal to 0.01.
So this event here
is identical to
that event up there.
This starts to look like
this expression.
p is the same as Mu.
But there is a little bit
of a difference in
the denominator terms.
So let's see what we can do.
Let's take this same event but
multiply both sides of the
inequality by a square
root of n.
This causes this denominator
term to become just square
root of n, and we get a square
root of n term in the
numerator on the other side.
This is an equivalent
description of the event.
Now we can multiply both sides
of this inequality by sigma--
actually the denominators
on both sides by sigma--
and we obtain this equivalent
representation.
But now we notice that here we
do have the random variable Zn
that we wanted.
And so we managed to express
this event in terms of the
random variable Zn.
In particular what we have is
that this probability is the
same as the probability that
the absolute value of Zn is
larger than or equal to
0.01 square root of
n divided by sigma.
Then we can use the central
limit theorem approximation to
approximate this probability
by the corresponding
probability where we now use
a standard normal random
variable instead of the
Zn random variable.
So here, Z stands for a
standard normal random
variable with mean 0 and
variance equal to 1.
Let us now continue on a new
slide so that we have some
working space.
And here is the result that
we have derived so far.
If somebody gives us the value
of n, we would like to be able
to calculate this probability
using this approximation.
However, there's a slight
difficulty because sigma is a
function that depends on
p, and it is not known.
However, as we discussed when
we first started the polling
problem, we do know that
sigma is always less
than or equal to 1/2.
And this suggests that we could
use here the worst-case
value of the standard deviation,
replace sigma by
1/2 and instead look at
this probability here.
How are these two probabilities
related?
Which direction does
the inequality go?
A sketch will be useful here.
Z is a standard normal, and
it's centered at 0.
Somewhere here, we have a value
of 0.02 square root n.
And somewhere further out, we
have the value of 0.01 square
root n divided by sigma.
Why are these two values
ordered this way?
Since sigma is less than 1/2, 1
over sigma is bigger than 2.
So this expression here
is bigger than
this expression there.
Since the inequality goes this
way, now we can compare these
two events.
This event, that Z is larger
in absolute value than this
number, is the probability of
this tail of the distribution.
And we will have a similar
probability from the other end
of the tail of the
distribution.
Here we're talking about the
probability of being larger
than or equal to this number,
which would correspond only to
this part of the tail and,
similarly, a small part of the
tail from the other side.
The blue event is smaller
than the red event.
This is the probability of the
blue event, so it's going to
be no larger than the
probability of the red event.
Now if somebody gives us a value
of n, we should be able
to calculate this probability.
How do we calculate it?
The probability that the
absolute value is above a
certain number is equal to the
probability of this tail plus
the probability of that tail.
But because of the symmetry of
the normal distribution, this
is twice the probability of
each one of the tails.
What is the probability
of this tail?
It's 1 minus the probability
of whatever is below that.
So it's 1 minus.
And the probability of being
below that, this is the
standard normal CDF evaluated
at 0.02 square root n.
So we do have now an expression
for the desired
probability, or at least a
bound for it, which is
expressed in terms of the
standard normal CDF.
If somebody gives you a value
of n, you can plug in here.
If n is 10,000, then square
root of n is 100.
And this number becomes
equal to 2.
And so in this case, what we
obtain is that the probability
of interest is less than
or equal to 2 times 1
minus Phi of 2.
Now we invoke the standard
normal table.
From the normal table, we obtain
that this quantity is
equal to twice 1 minus 0.9772,
which evaluates to 0.046.
So if we use 10,000 people in
our sample, then we will get
an accuracy of one percentage
point with very high
probability.
The probability that we do not
meet the specification so that
the accuracy that we get is
worse than one percentage
point, that probability
is quite small.
It's 0.046.
That is 4 and something
percent.
This is pretty good.
And suppose that your boss now
tells you, I only want the
probability of not meeting
the specs to be 5%.
You look at this result, and
you say, with 10,000, I
achieved a probability
of a large error
that's less than 5%.
This means that I probably have
some leeway and that I
can reduce the size
of my sample.
What could the size of
the sample be and
still meet those specs?
What we're trying to do here
is that we have this
approximation for the
probability of interest, and
we want to set this probability
to a value of 0.05.
Then we want to ask, what is
the value of n that will
result in this particular
probability of
not meeting the specs?
Now we can do the algebra.
And we find that this
corresponds to requiring that
phi of 0.02 square root n
to be equal to 0.975.
What's the interpretation
of this?
We want to choose n so that
the probability of the two
tails is 5%.
This means that we want this
probability here to be 2 and
1/2 percent.
This means that the probability
of whatever is to
the left of this number should
be 0.975, including the tail.
This means, again, that we have
to look at the standard
normal table and ask, what's the
value for which the CDF is
equal to 0.975?
So we look around, and we find
0.975 to be here, and it
corresponds to 1.96.
This tells us that 0.02
square root n
should be equal to 1.96.
Then we solve for n, and we find
that the value of n is
9,604, which is indeed some
reduction from the 10,000 that
we had originally.
How does this relate
to the real world?
When you read newspapers about
polls, you will never see
sample sizes that are
about 10,000.
You will usually see sample
sizes of the order of 1,000,
sometimes even smaller.
How can they do that?
Well, they can do that because
the specs that they impose are
not as tight as the specs
that we have here.
Usually, they tell you that
the results are accurate
within three percentage points,
let's say, instead of
one percentage point.
And by moving from 0.01 to 0.03,
and if you repeat those
calculations, you will find that
the sample size of about
1,000 will actually do.